hey folks we're back i'm here with louis
anderson and uh we didn't get a chance
to talk about uh life with louie this is
your new show right is that right it's
an animated program and a minute showing
i never realized how hard
it would be to make an animated show no
i mean it was a lot of work it was like
it's like thousands of people yeah i
worked on the simpsons a few years ago
and people don't realize it was just it
was just a ton of people working around
the clock just to make 21 hours 24 days
or is it no it's 24 weeks i knew i'd get
it
it's 24 weeks to make one half hour show
yeah and
i mean that's a
that's not worth it
it's just not it's just not that's not a
good deal i i got very little i got like
a buck a minute yeah not a good not a
good deal at all no i'm just getting at
least three
and no it was actually very it was a
great experience because i took my
family and all that material from my
family growing up and put it in an
animated situation we could exaggerate
it and make it fun and now there's a
there's a character in there who's based
on your father is that right that's
right conan
that's how dad talked andy sorry in that
wig
[Laughter]
[Music]
your dad sounds a little like roseanne i
think i knew roseanne
no my dad was a is this real ornery
character from my act that i that really
came to life during this series and it
really worked i mean you know it was a
lot of fun in fact my dad's dead and
every time we did him it was like he was
there
which was terrible
i mean if you knew my dad yeah
no he wasn't he wasn't a mean guy never
hit us carried a gun
he never shot it he just go
much more effective exactly
what about your mom is your is your mom
in this show too then my mom's in the
show and uh you know you become your
parents like i can't throw a bag out
really it's really sick because my mom
would always go what are you doing i'm
throwing the oh that's a good bag
you can't get bags like that anymore
well how'd we get it we're lucky
you know she was just wacky like that
you know she and she would uh
my mom was would point out things to you
that made no sense when she was driving
she was you know shirley's daughter
works in that building louie
and surely is
oh you know her she's got that little
blind chihuahua
right mom
did you take your pills today mom
but so so you know that we tried to
incorporate that that kind of stuff of
my mom being that real person
and my dad being you know the only time
i ever saw my dad emotional was when he
find boxes the grocery store was
throwing out
oh my god they're throwing these boxes
away
jesus is louie get him
we'll put your mom's bags in them
connect with him emotionally i mean that
was it i go all right dad sure let's
take the boxes
you know so it was those kind of things
and i i didn't realize how many people
had kind of crazy
family members because people come up to
me and all all the time and say you know
my mom and dad were a lot like yours
no now are you worried at all that you
know you describe your mother and your
father are you going to become the same
kind of person really i mean do you
think i will tell you i mean i remember
my dad
you know wearing boxer shorts and people
would come over and he'd be digging him
out of his ass you know
i mean that's what dads do i know that
sounds terrible but he'd be going hey
nice to meet you yeah
you know the whole family oh my god
you know
and i never thought i'd wear i woke up
one day and i had them on i go when did
the transition happen
they just grew yeah i fart when i pee
now oh
so
all right
um that's funny i i don't remember
asking
well i'm thinking back and i did that i
didn't mean it i didn't mean it in an
offensive way
people are always offended by that but i
mean everybody you know their dad that
was my dad's signature piece
a lot of people do the wizard of oz my
dad did
that his finest work now uh so now
you're leaving here with me
no you didn't gross me out at all i
enjoyed it that's my character
i'm replaying it in my mind now as we
speak
now i i understand you're leaving now
and it's right back on the road for you
is that right we're going to vegas uh
valleys the 14th through the 27th okay i
think we got that yeah
yeah and then i'm going uh
where the hell am i going
well there's a winchell's open all night
so you're in good shape yeah all right
well i enjoyed being here it's a lot of
fun i i'm glad i got to do this show
well i hope you come back soon i will it
was really nice meeting you thank you
watch for the new show everybody
life with lily it's going to be on fox
we'll take a break be right back louie
anderson